you
[Music]
this is David Deutsch man this is David
Deutsch man that's brother for the last
12 years David has held over 1200 babies
at Scottish Rite hospital hey David
when can I raise my voice after the
titles appear
[Music]
at Children's Healthcare of Atlanta
you'll find David volunteering as a baby
buddy a person that spends time holding
babies who were delivered prematurely or
requires special medical attention when
I first came to work for the hospital
and they gave me a little debut hold and
the Child Life person walked by and said
hey you hold debuts I've got a job for
you and I just loved it
I became nicknamed by a few nurses as
the baby whisperer but I'd be given a
baby who was screaming and crying you'd
be amazed how quickly they can calm down
because the babies stay in the hospital
for a long period of time most parents
can't stick around mainly because their
maternity leave runs out or they have
other kids at home that's where David
comes in David has gone on to hold
countless babies in the neonatal
intensive care unit providing not only
companionship but other medical benefits
as well just ask nurse Angie we find
that holding also can help mitigate some
pain so when our babies have heal six
done and they're being held they react
so much better than when they're not
held david has done this for so long now
when he takes a baby into his arms you
can see the baby relaxed because David's
so relaxed so you feel the baby's in
good hands
if you're a retiree I would say you get
off your button do something
volunteer doing something and there are
a lot of different ways of doing it
doesn't have to be in a Children's
Hospital I know it meant a lot to the
moms and the dads too but what it meant
for me I really feel like I'm the one
who benefited
[Music]
this is what it sounds like when 3,500
people are eating together another 3,500
and another
in total today the Shirdi Sai Baba
temple in Maharashtra India will serve
lunch to at least 40,000 people for free
and this happens every day 365 days a
year
the temple was built in 2008 around a
specific philosophy by spiritual leader
Sai Baba Baba HRT take correct ID before
Carnival hae has passed our score
my name is aja this is the man in charge
mera naam Sanjay lips punkin bar hey
Mara my personal I'm a supervisor case
it's a comfortable he supervises the
kitchen or mega kitchen as this is one
of the largest in Asia the day it starts
at 6:30 in the morning
except may teen solo artist resubmitting
saw felt a solo concert a possible what
I didn't mean Rashad Allahabad as
variation wrote I not POTUS vigée but no
time some people are cooking vegetables
some clean utensils some are responsible
for the bread you get it
[Applause]
everyday the meal is different but the
ratio is always the same column a if
green sub G or a cardinal sub G dal
chapati rice it not get this off to make
these plates for forty thousand people a
day it takes a lot of food here in the
numbers three point three tons of bread
two tons of vegetables nearly one ton of
lentils and half a ton of dessert now to
make all this food the kitchen requires
a lot of power a sub-sahara ischemia
number of the population base a lot of
it the roof is covered in solar panels
so it's clear this temples initiatives
are something to be proud of Santa Rosa
is very much a possibility
[Music]
basically anywhere there are people that
want to be hurt or want to get something
off their chest I bring mobile suit to
them and give them the option to either
record spit some poetry sing rap the
self express really
[Music]
[Applause]
mobile stew is basically a recording
studio that I started out of my car I
was trying to solve a problem and that
problem was equal access to musical
equipment or recording studio young
people from different neighborhoods can
all access pass to do we can separate
mobile suits of people yeah we're going
under Street break all the bones of the
way so when I get to the spot I pull
over and crack the trunk get out all the
equipment hook up the microphone the mic
stand then they see me pull up in the
mix board and I start playing beats with
my sight foreheads that you brought to
get into this everyone starts to come
over and wants to express themselves on
the microphone and at the same time that
they're doing that I'm recording it so I
give them a version of what they said
it's like a audible snapshot so there
was this young man that was murdered in
Dorchester there's a whole bunch of
people that oh like they really wanted
to get revenge I Drive through a mobile
stool and basically I'm giving them the
option to express themself I kind of
realized that mobile stools and just as
simple as I thought it was there was
de-escalating people and so we're like
this is de-escalating how can we use
this to deescalate or national crisis
which was cops killing kids
cops particularly killing young black
men
we had the opportunity at that same time
to come together musically which means
mobile student do the important aspect
of working with the officers and young
people together there's a kind of
different kind of a bond when you know
someone not just as an officer arresting
them or having to see them when
something bad happens right after all
that stuff started happening I started
getting calls from the Boston Public
Schools walking into an elementary
school is a little bit different because
we're talking about a classroom that was
supposed to be the worst class in the
school at the time you know special
needs young people that have been
through some serious trauma and I found
out that almost all the kids in there
were musically inclined they wanted to
be a rapper or a singer or a poet to see
the young person excited about something
good that they're doing and I get to
provide that moment that's was
gratifying to me these guys deserve to
have the opportunity to learn how to
record you know they deserve the ability
to express themselves
you got this ability to get yourself
heard even if it's just the whole
neighborhood in that moment makes people
feel like valued that's something like
that comes to them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
home for me first was a piece of mind
where you come home and you're always
safe
that's what home means to me especially
for my children before I moved into this
home six months ago I was living in the
shelter to get my own home it was just
breathtaking but there was nothing in it
I am Kristen Tsui and I'm a designer at
Hummel Design everything in this
warehouse you see is donated we work
with homeless and domestic abuse
shelters with families that are moving
out of those shelters and into homes and
a lot of times they have nothing but the
clothes on their back that's where we
step in and we provide the furniture for
them but then we also go back and
decorate and provide like those little
details that make your house a home and
makes it your home without our help
about 46 percent of families coming out
of the shelter go right back in with our
help that statistics goes down to 1% I'm
a direct care worker and I work with
older elder people before I live in the
shelter the boyfriend that I was living
with was emotionally and physically
abusive to me one day I woke up and I
just said I wasn't taking that anymore
today we met with Danielle and we just
talked with her a little bit found out
about her backstory it sounds like she
has come out of the shelter and now has
been in a house with basically no
furniture she has a few pieces but no
beds no you know chairs no table so we
talked with her a little bit about what
she wants in her home we went to the the
home and we took measurements and just
walked through each room what dinner
looks at my house now we all sit
together but we sit on the floor the
priorities was to have my silverware
bows and spoon stuff the things for us
to eat out of and ready to put on the
floor for us as we didn't have these
when I first started here I didn't
realize that people were living this way
when you walk into a home that is
completely empty and families are living
there and have lived there for months
it's shocking because you don't think of
it
[Music]
but on that Friday when we reveal a
house I just I just love the energy from
our volunteers to the families that are
getting these you know new homes really
I just I can't get enough of that
feeling and that's why I've stayed here
for for so long I thought oh my kids are
gonna be amazed I haven't really told it
was going on I just told the neighbors
getting some beard so they don't even
know that the whole house is gonna be
down so I know they're gonna be a style
and a half so it just makes me very
happy
[Music]
it's like a magazine
from zero to a miracle with the Hat I
love you all for this I mean this is
amazed this is just happiness to me so
be able to walk into a home and have
your friends and family there and you're
able to just show them comfort and joy
that that means a lot to me and I hope
that one day I can give back just what
was given to me
you
[Music]